[Musique]
total auquel oui beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
excusez moi il est où le lapin c'est pas
la politique
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu gardes en spectacle avec la mutuelle
je voulais pas au début en main ben je
vois ça chantal morini-bosc que tout de
suite ses parts
[Applaudissements]
oui
mais
ils appellent ça nous va vachement bien
voilà pour l'instant sans rigoler c'est
isabelle qui est beaucoup mieux hein
parce que l'on disputé sans ridicule
et attention la grenade chantal goya en
tout cas vous deux vous avez trouvé
votre rôle
gouda
[Musique]
ma vie
sous le panda qui est très rare je
commence à avoir une idée paris s'il
tonne
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]